encuentra a x y verifica tu respuesta
donde x entre 3 es igual a 14
ok tenemos aquí esta ecuación que nos
dice que la variable x que es la que
estamos buscando si la dividimos entre 3
nos da 14 y para encontrar el valor que
debe de tomar esta variable x para que
se satisfaga a esta ecuación o sea que
para que x entre 13 igual a 14 lo que
tenemos que hacer es hacer que se quede
la x solita del lado izquierdo del igual
y bueno tener x entre 3 es exactamente
lo mismo a tener un tercio multiplicando
a x cierto entonces estas dos ecuaciones
realmente nos están diciendo exactamente
lo mismo ahora como le vamos a hacer
para que la x que solita del lado
izquierdo pues que la x se quede solita
del lado izquierdo significa que tenemos
aquí x x 1 o sea una sola x y pues lo
que podemos hacer es multiplicar por 3 o
sea porque aquí la x la estamos
multiplicando por 3
y dividiendo entre 3 y entonces estos
dos se van a cancelar y nos va a quedar
x por 1 que es simplemente x ahora hay
que recordar que todo lo que hagamos del
lado izquierdo del igual lo tenemos que
hacer también del lado derecho para que
se preserva esta igualdad ok y lo mismo
sucede en esta ecuación de hecho vamos a
hacerlo para que veais que realmente son
la misma ecuación si multiplicamos por 3
y este se va a cancelar con este y aquí
también tenemos que multiplicar por 3
entonces lo que tenemos es cualquier
cosa que es nuestra x dividida entre 3 y
después multiplicada por 3 o sea la
dejamos tal cual como está igual a 14
por 3 14 por 3 es 42 y lo mismo pasa por
acá 3 por un tercio es lo mismo que 3
por 1 entre 3 o sea un 1 por cualquier
cosa 1 por cualquier cosa es esa misma
cosa o sea x
ya la tenemos por aquí x igual a 14 por
3 que es 42 muy bien ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es verificar que esta respuesta
o sea que x e igual a 42 es una
respuesta correcta y la forma de hacer
eso es sustituir 42 en lugar de la equis
tenemos que hacer que si ponemos el 42
en lugar de legis o sea si ponemos 42
entre 3 eso es exactamente igual a 14 ok
cuánto es 42 entre 3 42 63 es 14 aunque
14 si es igual a 14
entonces listo ya verificamos nuestra
respuesta 42 si lo dividimos entre 3 si
es igual a 14